for me that process is quite painstaking
and just very slow I am I think this is
true of many writers I'm nya it takes me
ages to write a sentence you know and my
day job is at where I'm an administrator
which is terrifically difficult for me
it really is and for reasons that are
perhaps not would not be evident to you
know most administrators I mean there
are many difficulties associated with
administration but for me the big one is
that I can't write I just got capped off
an email you know I can't just - one off
I have to look at it and turn it over
and you know see that it's you know
written with you know as if it could be
you know written on a headstone
somewhere and and that's not good that's
not good so but one of the things that
one has acquired as opposed is the
patience from that are the patience to
go slowly comparatively slowly we're
talking about
in other words spend a couple of days
right in the poem even though it looks
as if of course it was written in about
five minutes flat that's the whole the
whole idea as you know is that it takes
it takes a week to do that so just to be
alert to that and I'd also again at the
risk of being tiresome here of of
cherishing cherishing ignorant very
basic principle at work here if I know
what I'm doing you probably will do and
vice versa it's as simple as that if I
know what I'm doing you know what I'm
doing
what's the point there is no point we
should go and watch a movie you know
there is no point and even starting if
we both know what's happening and the
only way one can be sure of that
is for the first person involved ie the
writer for
reader writer writer reader is not to
know what's going on that doesn't mean
that one's has left one's brain outside
the door absolutely not because the
other side of this actually is that it
requires much more in the way of
intelligence than most of us most of us
can manage it really requires an
extraordinary you know intensive focus
on reading those words as they come out
of that place of Unknowing
so the focus of knowing upon unknowing
and the negotiation back and forth to
and fro between not knowing and knowing
and not knowing and knowing that's
that's where it gets done and it's only
but it's only only only if you properly
respect ignorance that there's half a
chance